[Música]
é uma forma de otimizar a criatividade
ao longo desta deste dia
já vimos várias áreas onde utilizava a
criatividade e utiliza criatividade no
ensino das ciências experimentais ante o
que é que eu criei criei há quatro anos
um conceito onde relaciona criatividade
ciência e sustentabilidade
assisti várias sessões em várias
formações ao longo destes anos porque eu
sou professor onde um 01 um kit
criatividade nas aulas criatividade
despertem a criatividade das crianças
andei estamos a pensar mas o que querem
com a criatividade nas aulas o que
queira com criatividade enfim deixe
ficar preta michael disco vegas por
problema mas não temos materiais
causados nas aulas há materiais que o
investimento é muito grande como é que
tem de fazer aulas criativas muito
simples pensar em uma situação que vou
partilhar convosco uma visita ao museu
de arte moderna em um monte
havia um jovem estava jovem artista
eu acho que estava com uma exposição
nessa sala quando jovem esposa suas
obras estava uma obra que levou centenas
de pessoas a contemplar essa obra vamos
dizer qual era o meu de cinco minutos a
olhar para o abraço muito sincero a obra
era um aquário vazio e que foi colocado
lá duas bolas do basca norma em cima
estavam centenas de pessoas
olha aquela prova um aquário vazio com
duas bolas para as canadenses
vamos dizer que esta ideia acompanhou
durante três ou quatro anos
qual era a minha questão eu não consegui
estar olha aquela o
usar durante tanto tempo outras obras
que vive no mesmo museu e teve 15 e 20
minutos
isso não saiu da ideia na cabeça quando
costuma dizer depois das formações onde
eu estive criatividade que pensar no
esquente o que é que eu possa fazer
contributo possa ajudar como docente
para estimular a criatividade
a minha opinião é que todas as pessoas
são criativas
todas elas temos é uma forma de frente
ser um estímulo watts na sua
criatividade é uma pessoa muito simples
eu vou relacionar criatividade ciências
e sustentabilidade tem trabalhado nesses
últimos quatro anos como a faixa etária
que eu acho que tenha que ser de
atividade enorme são crianças dos quatro
aos 12
muitos dão um dos kits chama os kits que
o tunis e do as crianças para fazer este
processo de ensino ciência recorrendo a
criatividade não estão montados e eu
idealizo uma experiência e sai outra
totalmente diferente melhor que o que eu
ia me ver as crianças têm uma
criatividade campo vossa tomar e pensei
um pouco mas será que é possível ensinar
a ciência despertará os nossos jovens
paciência otimizando criatividade
consegue conciliar criatividade em
ciência que os vistos aqui ao longo do
dia que sim consegue desatar a música
conceito mas como é que vamos disputar
essa criatividade das crianças
as aulas têm alguns dias 28 29 30 alunos
como é que eu vou conseguir despertar a
criatividade os laboratórios por vezes
não amanhã como é que eu vou fazer isto
e eu pensei
o processo da construção criatividade
não é muito enfrenta o método
experimental não tinha isso todos eu a
sinto em três ou quatro princípios que
na minha opinião são comuns porque eu
não tenho visto porque eu não tento
então muito simples porque é em diversos
objetos de desperdício que iriam para o
lixo idéias um caminho qualquer minha
criatividade e eficiência
eu sou franchi na sustentabilidade
posso só dizer e porque aí com outros
oradores à hora do almoço que traz
elemento e a apresentação do centro
ciência viva vitae vi oferta formativa e
sabem o que o trouxe do pavilhão do
conhecimento no final da noite trouxe
alguma oferta formativa os chapéus 14/3
shacks enormes do lixo o lixo material
desperdício garrafas importante quanto
os outros todos saíam com os filetes eu
sei com três choques enormes do bicho
porque eu estava é ver na atividade que
estavam sei lá propostas mas já estava a
pensar o que queria fazer com aquelas
garrafas com que os cofre com a qual se
pratica sobraram durante a sessão
é isso que eu faço muito simples é um
conceito extremamente simples e o
conceito que nenê
eu não gostava acesso eu não sei o quê
acesso
sou muito sincero não sei o que é certo
pra mim é esse nível de sucesso é ver é
fume cidade das crianças e é
indiscutível é felicidade das crianças
o miguel mas como é que estão numa salva
26 27 crianças sem cheta 8 ante e
conseguem estar 40 60 minutos chegou a
fazer há muito simples
posta criatividade e curiosidade
elas nunca vão saber o que vão fazer o
que vão construir e com isto não vai ver
as crianças juntaram os 3 constantes
criatividade educação na parte da china
fez comentários e sustentabilidade
eu não sou muito professor de teoria
quando costuma dizer sou professor prata
quis comentar o que eu pensei nesta
apresentação e se eu demonstrar
realmente fazemos fazemos crianças
eu sou um mero orientador são as
crianças constroem constrói a e não tem
o kit não aplicam o conceito quem depois
tirando do kit não a criança recebe os
materiais constrói o que é público que o
conceito científico feito muito básico
áreas das ciências experimentais e
depois leva para casa e consegue fazer
uma réplica duas retas quiser uma das
frases que ficou foi uma criança de seis
anos
nós vamos fazer um alfinete cf que era
intitulada uma viagem pelo universo
o que nós fizemos foi em fuck total de
uma embalagem de iogurte e e furtam
tinha como bach eu vou aprender o
conceito com o ar e visto é invisível e
ocupa espaço com deus abriu a embalagem
estava presente não estava armado quando
chavão etapas com uma pequena por linha
nova com poesia ea criança eu estava e
compreendia que lá dentro estava o a rua
e no final desta oficina da criança diz
branco os colegas miguel fantástico o
suficiente está afectada
eu se fosse mas ainda mais incrível com
seis anos esteja tudo muito e acho que
eu estava fora e agora consegui
construir com uma irmã para minha prima
pela prima e paz pessoas todas que eu
quiser
exatamente é este o conceito é isto é
ideia que o defendo enfim fiesp metal
com base na criatividade
vamos ver por exemplo tem duas tampas
num pólo i ching pequena vaz de mandar
um pau de chuva e dois pregos outro isso
às vezes um pouco terá mas é mais fácil
pisar que vou fazer é simples toda a
criança constrói o seu kit utiliza um
motel com 56 anos do turismo martel
sobre nossas mais curto e depois disso
eu gosto ir ao motel como do meu pai
martel retardar importante a criança ter
esta noção dos materiais
o cae o que construímos o que
construímos puxa pela vossa criatividade
um sistema como está nos conteúdos
programáticos um sistema de engrenagens
o nível do primeiro ciclo construir o
que chamamos um sistema de rodas
dentadas criança construir um sistema
que vai aceitar esta era a minha ideia
inter tam uma criança que tinha um
marcador na mesa e fez eu tenho um pé
filmes harry potter
o boneco é o que nós pensamos
vou aqui colocar ainda assim ficou os
olhos inscritos para que os olhos
exemplo vai provocar um boneco sim
o méxico vai usar uma corda ou outra mas
mais uma criança diz
eu não fiz chuo o sistema das rodas
dentadas que são aplicados em muitos
objetos miguel eu aprendi ontem com
minha professora eu fiz um corpo humano
fez o corpo mas sim cabeça tronco e
membros
eu não disse nada a própria criança
chegou esta edição o caio eu tinha de
avisar simplesmente um sistema de rodas
dentadas ea criança chegou a 1 com o
site do corpo marca quando vi o corpo na
outra atividade para perceber é
profissão é surreal conhecida que nós
fazemos aqui uma reação química
vamos dizer que vamos fazer uma explosão
a criança fica toda entusiasmada porque
não sai sempre que fala num cientista é
um indivíduo que tem o cabelo em pé
louca eo perguntas livres mas porque
consciente isto tem que ser o que tem
que ver o que o mp não essa cidade
mas é uma expulsão miguel góis temos por
vant temos nem que seja pelo green e
temos que os anjos e colocam aqui uma
pastilha de freio e com pouca água e vão
tapar e vão perceber como é que funciona
a proporção é chato
o avião é projetar podemos abordar
também o ar vai ocupando o espaço vai o
outro faz a maravilha já trouxe contato
o tempo que é um caminho que permite
estudar forças com quatro campi
são paulo 20 wadabwa uma pelinha deixe a
fantástica tem um problema para os mais
pequenos é o são criativos mas não tem
ainda capacidade para encher o balão
outro cops com as parafusos restos de
bastidores
podemos falar da força da gravidade que
os cortes são em 3d
podemos falar nem vai se dar algum
objeto e fazemos o que nós chamamos o
saltitão e é projetar imagina uma sala
com 20 a 30 a projetar e assaltar o fato
e tal
isso é o que nós utilizamos para
explicar os sistemas hidráulicos cai
neste meio tempo fui temos voar mas
podemos utilizar o youtube vemos
normalmente a água com corante alimentar
também e mails perceberem a tv em
comparação entre o a fazer ecoar e
depois fazerem com a água então
abordando o tema do espaço a mais e
virar o astronauta é sair na rua ir pós
pasta pois podemos abordar como é que
flutua mostrou na alta ou não temos em
meses
isto tudo com o sentido criatividade
enfim das ciências experimentais e
sustentabilidade
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]